welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and ro1 is a Star Wars story that
oddly gets better and better with age
largely because it celebrates everything
Star Wars fans love incredible visuals
deep cuts to the lore actual wars a
Darth Vader who's really scary again and
a plot so straightforward it could be
summed up in a few yellow words ahead of
the rise of Skywalker I'm going to comb
back through rogue one to find all the
new details and Easter eggs that we miss
back in my 2017 breakdown back when our
work space was haunted with random
ghosts who popped up in the background
and before we begin
thanks to Monday comm for sponsoring
this breakdown money.com is a super
intuitive team management tool with a
platform that's suitable for any size
team from two freelancers working
together to thousands of workers
worldwide or dozens of rebels trying to
bring down the Empire something I tested
because I actually used money calm to
make this break down we use it for a lot
of our videos to keep track of all this
stuff and and sometimes the best way to
do that is to put in characters names
and places anyway let's start at the
beginning of the rebels mission to steal
the Death Star plans that mission began
with a prologue on the planet lamu now
there's no classic opening crawled of
rogue one instead director Gareth
Edwards cast a shadow on the planet's
rings creating this grey triangular
shape that evokes the opening image of
the original Star Wars which opened with
Vader's Star Destroyer the Devastator
chasing down the ship that ends this
film the tanta for it is on lamu where
director Orson Critic finds Galen R so
forcing him to finish the building the
Death Star killing his wife creating an
enemy in the Imperial ranks that would
later become the Empire's fatal flaw we
can see this as task one of the rebels
mission because without Galen none of
this would be possible they're actually
more cool Easter eggs here meant to
evoke the original Star Wars moisture
vaporators and blue bantha milk both
paralleling Luke's moisture farm on
Tatooine and critic is dressed in white
with his death troopers in black meant
as a reversal of the opening shots of
Vader in black flanked by white strong
troopers and we move on to tasks - of
this rebel mission with casseon and or
receiving Intel and k2 a so breaking
Galen's daughter gen or so from prison
on a planet whoa Bonnie an anagram for
obi-wan also bueno
notice that the rebel calls her by this
alias the name Liana is actually
reference to the alias given to Mara
Jade by the emperor when he introduced
her to Grand Admiral Thrawn in the dark
force rising book now on to task 3
casting in bringing Jenna to gavin for
to brief her they recreated the rebel
base set perfectly and they filled it
with cameos by gonk droids and astromech
droids I think you can actually see r2
this early in the background mon mothma
is played by genevieve o'reilly who
played the character in the deleted
scene from Revenge of the Sith along
with Jimmy Smits coming back as Bail
Organa general Jan tadhana is also
present
he's now played by Ian McKellen II from
Game of Thrones now task 4 of this plan
takes them to Jenna to find Sagar era in
his group called the partisans among
them are the brothers Ed Rio and benthic
two tubes actually before joining the
partisans benthic was previously part of
the cloud riders whom we saw in the solo
movie also in this group is this little
guy we team QB he's played by actor
Warwick Davis continuing his tradition
of playing characters with w names in
the Star Wars movies like wicket the
Ewok wold and weasel from Phantom Menace
and wall oven in the force awakens
throughout the Jetta plateau Jin and
cassian past a bunch of Easter eggs
including an imperial probe droid and
these two fellas dr. Cornelius Amazon
and Ponda Baba you remember these two
d-bags is the ones who picked a fight
with Luke and obi-wan and Maz Eisley
that did not end well for them there's
actually a whole removed backstory with
these two being tracked by another
character Tampa's 'la and Kayson bog we
saw the two of them and one of the
trailers for rogue one case involves one
of Emma's ons Dee crane eiated surgery
experiments gone awry this case would
have ended with their deaths in the
cantina in-laws Leslie the de created
was actually later used on Dryden boss's
yacht in soloist our story
Ginny Cassie and also meat-based Albus
and Sharon M way described as the
guardians of the wheels guardians of the
Wills referencing the ancient
storytellers the Wills in George Lucas's
original framing narrative in an early
draft of his Star Wars script in way
says may the force of others be with you
which is actually from an early version
of that Star Wars script which is later
changed to may the force be with you
before Lucas decided to capitalize force
and make it old thing which would later
have medic lorian's is tasks five of the
rebels victory is more of a long game of
playing the Empire's bureaucracy and
middle management
against itself a well-known tactic of
outgunned resistances against occupying
regimes in this case it's Galen or so
using Bodhi Brooks defection to drive a
wedge between rival Imperial officers
critic in turkan in the Star Wars scene
where Vader forced choked Admiral mati
there's an empty chair at that table
which presumably belonged to critic
critic has to answer to Vader in his
castle on Mustafar the planet Vader
fought obi-wan on in Revenge of the Sith
his castle is based on old Ralph
McQuarrie art for the original trilogy
designed to parallel the structure of a
Jedi Temple except now it's kind of a
dam for lava which feeds its negative
energy there's a brief shot of Vader in
a back to healing tank edwards said that
he wanted a similar moment of
vulnerability as the shot of the back of
Vader's head that we briefly saw an
empire task 6 of the plan is to make
contact with Galen or so on yeah do even
though castings plan is to assassinate
Galen his overall step of the journey is
to confirm that the flaw he designed
into the Death Star is real the
character of Galen is based on J robert
Oppenheimer one of the developers of the
atomic bomb who later lamented over his
work in his famous speech called the
destroyer of worlds the destroyer of
worlds was actually the working title
for rogue one in the story treatment
Lucas Films John Knoll used to pitch
this story and when the film was
finished its reels were shipped out
under the name Los Alamos which was the
city in New Mexico known for its atomic
bomb testing sites but back on the Aven
for task 7 is to regroup with rebel
forces and convince them to fight
general Marek leads the x-wing blue
squadron a detail taken from the
original Star Wars which had to change
the x-wings from blue to red squadron
because the blue screens used for the
VFX Force the color blue to need to be d
saturated that's why our twos blue
paneling came off as a dark grey color
during the trench run scene the blue
squadron makes it through the scare of
shield gate and that base gets blown up
by the Death Star explaining why the
blue squadron is not around for the
Battle of Yavin the rebel Navy is led by
Admiral Radice leader in the last Jedi
the resistance names their flagship the
Radice after this war hero also during
the sequence you can hear a voice over
the PA ringing out this is a nod to hera
syndulla from Star Wars rebels her ship
the ghost can be seen among the rebel
fleet throughout the film as can their
astromech droid chopper now a small
group of rebels splits off to take
action and bode identifies their call
sign as
Rogue rogue one thus providing the
origin of the name of the rebel Rogue
Squadron in the original trilogy now
there's a tiny moment between Mon Mothma
and Bail Organa that more or less
connects this whole movie's plot to the
prequels and the original trilogy you
should be well doing the Clone Wars it
is lived in hiding it's the empress
purge yes I will send for you need
someone you can trust I would trust her
with my life captain Antilles
they're referring to obi-wan Kenobi one
of the few Jedi who escaped Oda 66 and
Revenge of the Sith now hiding on
Tatooine though more details of that
story won't soon be explored in the
Kenobi series and Organa is going to
send his adopted daughter Princess Leia
whom he literally trusts with his life
when he dies in Alderaan's destruction
and II Captain Antilles he summons is
Ramos Antilles his pilot scene at the
end of Revenge of the Sith and the end
of this film now task 8 of the plan
leads the crew to scare off' where they
must infiltrate the imperial shield
gates sneak into the Citadel Tower and
find the Death Star schematics and the
archives they use the old Star Wars
strike of masquerading and imperial
uniforms in as they sneak in we get the
Star Wars trademark line I've got a bad
feeling about a few more Easter eggs a
mouse droid buzzes around and k2o so
hacks another Imperial droid with the
same kind of rotary style stomp link
that r2 uses on a door lock in the Death
Star outside two stormtroopers chitchat
stormtroopers every similar conversation
about t-17s in the force awakens
in the archive room Jen reads off the
file names systems this detail became a
major plot point in the last Jedi
hyperspace tracking was how the first
order was able to follow the resistance
fleet even after their hyperspace jump
and then the battle heats up and we move
on to task 9 of the mission which
involves the rebel forces directly
engaging the scare of base confusing the
Empire forces long enough to bring down
the shield and allow the Death Star
plans to transmit through the rebel
fleet includes the ghost from rebels a
nebula B escort frigate which we saw in
the final scene of Empire and the Battle
of Endor GRS 75 medium transports which
we saw from the retreat from Hoth and
Empire as well as the Mon Calamari
cruisers and during this battle they
slipped in our kite footage from the
original Star Wars of gold leader John
Vander this is gold and red leader
Garvin grace this is red leader and they
also point out this specific pilot this
was the original red 5 and now that he's
dead it leaves the bread 5 position open
for Luke Skywalker to take it in the
Battle of Yavin now they're finally able
to open the shield gate with a
hammerhead Corvette which knocks one
Star Destroyer into another and both
crashed into the gates that plus bodis
patch and cherry flipping the master
switch allows Jin and Kassian to
transmit the plans up to the rebel ship
and that takes us to task 10 the final
step handoff the plans and escape Vader
now the Death Star has wiped out all the
heroes on the Scarab surface and now
Vader's ship the Devastator has arrived
turning rogue one into a story about
Darth Vader and these stolen plans
themselves and just a violent game of
keep-away between these two things now
check out another video I recently did
breaking down why this sequence is my
favorite / fate or moment but
essentially it's a highlight reel of
Vader using every attack we know he's
capable of using the Force to jam that
door and lock these rebels in a kill box
all the while a slow down coral version
of the Imperial March squeeze down over
them and it all ends with the plans
handed off to the Tantive 4 from Captain
Antilles - Princess Leia but right
before ITA's that he orders prepare the
escape
yeah one last detail connecting this all
to the opening of Star Wars because it
is those escape pods through which r2 in
Threepio slip through Vader's clutches
with these stolen plans and there you
have it
now again thank you to Monday comm for
helping me organize this rewatched
Monday comm it's to make every user feel
empowered and part of something bigger
than their own individual tasks and as a
result to boost collective productivity
and transparency just like how it simply
rebels in the rogue one crew were in
each of their own small ways all part of
something bigger than they ever could
have imagined so download Monday comm
today and give it a try
now again I covered even more details in
my original rogue one breakdown how all
the battle imagery was based on famous
war movies and since new rock stars has
already analyzed the new Star Wars films
since the force awakens we would love to
count down the weeks leading up to the
rise of Skywalker by doing these kinds
of rewatch 'as for the original trilogy
as well as the prequel films it just
takes a lot of time and resources to do
that
so one way that you can help us is by
becoming a patron of new rock stars
Digital Studios enough generosity we
just might be able to do these once a
week between now and December and as a
patron you're gonna get special access
to bonus content a lot of great stuff
just click on our patreon link in the
description how do you rank rogue one
among the Star Wars films comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
Twitter and Instagram @ gave us all new
rock stars and social media and new rock
stars and subscribe to us on YouTube for
more breakdowns and free watches too the
film you love and the films you love
even more after the film's follow it in
the series seriously disappoint you
[Music]